and i'm disappointed for anybody that
can't be a part of this whether due to
injury or whatever you know
disappointed for joel betonio obviously
uh all of our guys that can't be a part
of this
uh is disappointing to me but we have to
find a way
and that's what our charge is and that's
what we're working on today
this team is not my image it's the
cleveland browns we've established an
identity we did it
back in the spring we told the guys how
we're going to play we made sure that we
brought players in here that fit that
mold
and i think the guys understand
perfectly how we play and how we win
so doesn't change regardless of who's on
the sideline the players
understand dan that it really doesn't
matter
who's the head coach on on sunday
kevin stefanski brown's coach who will
not be available on sunday night when
the browns take on the pittsburgh
steelers for cleveland's first playoff
game in 18 years because kevin stefanski
tested positive earlier this week for
covet 19.
the nfl continues to take the position
that there is no
outbreak happening within the browns
organization because the nfl players
association works hand in hand with the
nfl
on these issues i believe that these are
the result of community spread these
infections these positives these close
contacts this unavailability of coaches
and players
it will not keep the game from happening
unless and until chris there's evidence
of an actual outbreak yesterday no new
positive tests for the browns
that's good but but but they're still in
the incubation period from sorry when
they played
right today's day four you could still
have positives today
tomorrow the next day sunday this could
go all the way up to sunday before they
come to the final conclusion through
contact tracing genomic sequencing
analysis of test results that it's good
to go
on sunday night and it wasn't until mid
to late morning on sunday that the week
17 game between cleveland and pittsburgh
got the all clear so this is going to
linger for a few days
the preparations continue without kevin
stefanski directly involved
and the browns are going to have to do
the best they can under the
circumstances wow this is the ultimate
next man up scenario
it is the ultimate next man up scenario
you know i i mean i i do agree with
kevin stefanski where
you know we kind of talked about this
yesterday on sunday i don't think it's
going to be like the teams will be like
oh man our head coach isn't out there
we're screwed we don't know what we're
doing
you know they're gonna have everything
set forth the game plan every
all the communication that needs to be
done going into a football game
that'll still be there so we can't
forget that but again
you know it's the second week in a row
where they're missing practice time
and not that you need again you you hear
me say this a lot i don't mean to you
know
beat beat the the drum here but you know
lack of
reps lack of being able to walk through
things you don't even need full
speed reps but to me just in my
experience
personally as a player and even like
teammates and other guys
man just being on the field and walk
throughs and seeing it in person
goes a lot farther than on the board
we're gonna make this
adjustment and do this and okay here's a
clip of this play and here's how we do
it the right way
hey that all helps but as you know just
like anything
reps are important to get out there and
do that and man
that's where i just two weeks in a row
without him without real
reps and practice that that's a little
worrisome no doubt about that
yeah because they're going against the
steelers team that that still has plenty
of great players and that
isn't affected by these issues they have
their head coach they have all their key
players
and they're practicing to go right on
sunday night
exactly yeah um rams receiver cooper cup
is off the covet 19 reserve list he
tested positive last week the 10 days
have expired he's back
buccaneers linebacker shaquille barrett
also off the covet 19 reserve list
that's good news for those two teams as
we go into the weekend
alvin kamara the saints running back who
when we last saw him wearing
one red shoe and one green shoe scored
six touchdowns against the minnesota
vikings
tested positive last week missed the
week 17
win over the panthers if the saints
bears game had been set for saturday he
wouldn't be available to play
sunday he is but it would have to happen
without practicing here's drew brees
from yesterday
talking about camara's ability to play
even if he wouldn't have practiced
everybody has their own formula you know
um and and i would say that
i think alvin's gonna be just fine you
know um i think it's all
it's something all of us have had to
deal with at some uh
in some way you know whether it be an
injury or whatever the at whatever the
absence is
um where you you you
have to find your way to prepare both
physically mentally emotionally
leading up to the game even with limited
reps
look i can't imagine them not letting
camaro play you do the mental reps you
do the film study this guy is a seasoned
veteran he's a pro
and he is highly skilled he'll be out
there on the field and he'll be part of
it
even if he's ultimately just a decoy
chris he's going to be out there
how can you not be out there when the
season is riding on it
michael thomas returned to practice
yesterday he's on injured reserve
technically still on injured reserve
just the window to return to practice is
open for him that will be helpful
taysom hill has a concussion confusing
to me i thought maybe he suffered the
concussion on wednesday because that's
how you would be limited because if you
have a concussion
you're not cleared to practice
apparently he suffered
a concussion on sunday yeah they left
the game and nobody ever said what
happened right
right and then and then maybe he's been
cleared to practice they just
chose to not go all out with them yeah
that's another one that we have to look
at and say maybe he won't be available
on sunday and that changes their offense
it takes away that wild card dynamic
no doubt i mean all three guys they're
big names right there
they're difference makers game changers
and the saints had problems
moving the football against the bears
when they played them back in week eight
i believe right
and you know again this saints team's
different than than now
but it's still a bearish defense that's
pretty damn good and chuck pagano
defensive coordinator who's pretty
smart you know i watched back that match
up of week 8 yesterday a little bit
hey he was all over some of the sean
payton drew brees stuff they like to do
in the past game
camara out of the backfield was a real
issue for the chicago
bears they didn't know how to handle him
so
that is where alvin kamara is so
important to their football team and
like we've talked about too drew
drew brees is not going to blow you away
with bombs and
lasers down the field he needs michael
thomas and alvin kamara
and he that's why they're important and
like mike you're right about the
practice stuff
i mean alvin kamara you know once you
get after out of your like
rookie year you know and really get into
year two
three and all those things uh as long as
you haven't missed ten weeks
okay yeah then you might need some
practice to get back in but if you
missed one or two games
a guy of alvin kamara's stature like
that practice is
it's it's nuanced yeah okay little
things here and there that you'd like to
be able to go out and do but
he's gonna understand the game plan the
coaching points that are made
of hey we want to run the route like
this and all that and i don't think
there'll be any issue and i would expect
them to be hitting on all cylinders
sunday
i mean i look at it this way a guy who
scored six touchdowns the last time we
see him who will be playing in a game 16
days later
i think we saw enough right on december
20. he won't forget where to go
know that albuquerque yeah he'll know
how to that's run the football
right hit the hole yeah yeah yeah you
have to you have to physically remove
him from the end zone and he may show up
in those red and green shoes i think it
will be worth
the second find because those definitely
good luck
shoes for alvin kamara so we expect to
see him on sunday afternoon
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports